hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einem neuen
video auf einem kanal meine lieben
freunde eventuell können sich einige von
euch noch daran erinnern dass ich vor
einigen jahren schon mal das spiel stars
table gespielt habe wegen mir hat es
doch sehr viele bugs das video über eine
million aufrufe bekommen ihr habt alle
mega lustig gefunden und die sache ist
nur dass die inhaber von stars table
mich gewandt haben weil sie meint nicht
zu alt für das spiel
[Musik]
ich meine da wurde 22 jahren noch
starten label spiel auf jeden fall habe
ich mir jetzt ganz nett hier einen neuen
account erstellt und zwar heißt meine
reiterin jacqueline spyder tiger und
mein pferd heißt pumpkin pirate er fragt
mich nicht wie ich auf die namen
gekommen bin
wir befinden uns jetzt auf jeden fall in
der stars table welt also wir können
hier grob um reiten können uns hier ein
bisschen umschauen wert sind dass die
vorne für mädels hallo laura claude
chabrol stehen hier pumpkin pie mit
laura und charlotte kann ich hier sogar
mit denen chatten hallo ich bin luca und
spiele stars was macht ihr sehr
wahrscheinlich bin ich auch co star
state okay das hat meine figur jetzt
gesagt und schnüre wenige minuten später
ok einige zeit ist vergangen ich habe
gerade noch kurz eine quest gemacht ich
schaue mir einer gar
ja freunde habe ich
ich bin jetzt hier an dem laden und kann
mir jetzt hier sachen aussuchen für die
ich kein geld allerdings brauchen
pumpkin pirate und ich wirklich keine
dinge die wir uns jetzt hier irgendwie
kaufen wollen also wir sind auch so
komplett glücklich breiten hier durch
die wälder wo bin ich eigentlich gerade
hallo konrad was geht denn bei dir aber
hallo ich grüße dich und ein stattliches
pferdenarr dankeschön conny finde
konrads verlorene werkzeuge haben wir
metall reihe von einer harke suche
entlang der straße an der die masken
paare dann gebt mir ein bisschen gas
hier haben wir müssen hier für den
konrad natürlich seine werkzeuge wie
verliert man überhaupt keine werkzeuge
hier vorne liegt schon was auf den boden
hier liegt auch noch so ein bisschen was
auf dem boden hier vorne die genaue
ursache ab das war's konrad ruh dich
geld jetzt oder war jacqueline ich habe
angst näher an dieser maschine
heranzutreten ich bin noch nicht mutig
genug acom pumpkin pie mit la stampa
wachsen und die da vorne kann da
langlauf mir die landis armstrong der
laufen hinterher doch pumpkin pie
ritters da hinten ist unser ziel so
krass ist ja auch egal
hier ist auf jeden fall der jetzt können
wir mit dem jasper jetzt hätte seinen
kopf der ball jetzt ein ganz ganz lang
war als wir ihn jetzt mal hier vorne
rein und ist hier etwas besonderes was
passiert wenn ich hier runter falle kann
ich hier bin ich da ist er wieder
schnelle daher pumpkin pirate das war
das mädel was an dieser komischen
maschine vorbeireiten durfte aber ich
nicht und ich wollte die fragen die das
gwk pampa youtube ist langsam - schnecke
die sollen wir denn in dem tempo jemals
kriegen
sega kommt rein alleine da hin wo du
dahin auch hinten eine weiße was pumpkin
pie und ich lasse dich jetzt hier stehen
und du bleibst jetzt erst mal kurz
stehen und bleibst da stehen die leute
das parken pirate ich es hier gerade in
den busch und ich will dass der mich
vermisst 2000 jahre später da ich glaube
ich ich kann rücksitz
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
der zielgruppe kann ich um den baum
herum laufen
[Musik]
weil das dümmste spieljahres saatgut
freunde genug gelacht was haben wir denn
hier vorne was ist denn das finde
picknickkorb er die läuft ja mal sowas
von bescheuert na ja wir haben auf jeden
fall die aufgabe einen picknickkorb zu
wo ist eigentlich mein tag fährt
da gehen wir mal wieder hier auf pump in
pirate drauf das macht er was das denn
für ein monster wie noch ein ach du
scheiße ich würde sagen wir scheißen wir
auf den picknickkorb
das ist mir ehrlich gesagt egal ob diese
person ihren picknickkorb zurückkriegt
oder nicht wir schauen bei einem stopp
bei einer fia hat geschrieben hab ja ich
bin und ich bin neu hier punkt um punkt
wollen
wir uns dessen auf der kop nichts danke
für deine antwort ja wo bist ein paar
sekunden später ok freunde hat
geantwortet in ml arme stadt die ganz
sie ist also ein star stable freak und
man and more land hier wohl ml wie man
kölns die geändert oder frankfurt ffm
oder so ist es hier ist auch egal ich
würde sagen wir schauen einfach mal am
start vorbei dürfe
du bleibst mir hier stehen ich steig mal
eben ab ich muss jetzt eben eine
freundin suchen dass eine ganzen
langjährige freundin von mir die piazza
hier ist pipe the dragon caroline
rockland da steht einfach nur ein paar
pferde
hier ist die bohrer haben wir hier schon
jetzt jacqueline die luft die wie call
die johanna wo ist denn meine freundin
pia vielleicht wirst du wie sie einfach
mal ganz laut rufen ja bist du hier bist
du vielleicht hier vorne drin ja auch
nicht bist du vielleicht im brunnen nie
aber ich dass das hier ja die pia ja ich
bin's der lotus ab und zu komme ich
einfach auf die rückwärts laufend dann
hört ihr einfach nicht abrufen
ich mach nix und die läuft die ganze
zeit rückwärts navi wird sagen wir sehen
hier mal wieder pumpkin pirate auf sagt
man aufsatteln ich muss eigentlich noch
einige quests machen also ich muss nur
diesen picknickkorb wiederfinden
ich muss auch noch eine upgrade meine
stalls ausführen campari du bist du lahm
wie sonst schmecken schneck
schnickschnack bereiten jetzt trotzdem
war einfach ein bisschen rum um ein
kleines pferd magic tigers team bis
jetzt was besser ist als co2
vorne ist immer noch gar nicht lange
bitten das heißt ich schaue mich jetzt
hier auf dem berg mal ein bisschen um
erstmal straße ist versperrt wie man
kommt hier durch bis für alles auf was
und sie darf da lang reiten oder was die
nici kätzchen kompanie campari mit
solchen blöd mir da müssen wir gar nicht
kontakt haben ich kann springen ach du
heilige mutter gottes kann ja über
seinen stab hier immer eben
ich bin ja also in pferde sprache
fachsprache wird nein samaria park in
bayreuth langlauf nicht ins wasser das
wasser laufen will ich da ist der
willigen
ich kann doch nicht im wasser laufen
gerade schon gemerkt ich habe aus
versehen gerade summer rain gerufen das
liegt ganz einfach daran weil mein altes
pferd summer rain hieß und dann kommt ja
gebannt
hab dich selig ich schaue mal ob wir
hier vorne vielleicht rüberkommen wenn
ich ganz ganz schnell zur anderen seite
hin
ok
gelaufen doch
sind ist ja alles möglich in diesem
spiel hier oben über dem wert kann nicht
auflaufen ich glaube da bin ich auch in
meinem ersten teil schon lange laufen
dann kann ich hier in der st mein gott
nein nein
ok gerade noch so geschafft hier
forderten sternen
du hast einen stern gefunden
das ist das ist der stern den ich gerade
gefunden habt ihr vorne ist irgendwie so
ein kleines picknick m das ist der
moorland südstrand
ich drück xl auf weiter paritätisch mit
abstand das dümmste fährt auf der ganzen
welt ich will jetzt noch mal irgendwie
andere leute kennen lernen hier vorne
und hier laufen reiten auch gerade zwei
reiterinnen herkommt nachdem davor
stehen bei eva crane dorn bleibt stehen
eva um einkauf via bleibt hier ist ja
die mit der ich gerade die ganze dem
chat geschrieben habe hey hier prima um
genau pia heirate ich schreib dir mal
wieder was geht ab und gott das ist sie
gar nicht die hier heißt ja westram und
die hier heißt firebird hier ist ja mal
ein richtig blöd pia fei kann ich dir
irgendwie wir erben
jetzt habe ich dir als freund ist will
ich nicht ich will er die andere pia
aber ist ja auch egal freunde pumpkin
privat und ich genieße jetzt hier auf
jeden fall noch den sonnenuntergang hier
ist allerdings von der sonne aber
scheißegal wer das heutige video her
gefallen hat dann lass gerne mal einen
daumen hoch bei diesem video hier dafür
jacqueline spyder teige pumpkin pie ried
und mit cios logi luca viele von euch
wollten dass ich mal wieder stars table
spieler deswegen habe ich mir jetzt so
ganz nicht einen neuen account erstellt
ich hoffe du bist a stable team ist sie
mir nicht auch den wieder wegnehmen
werde die hast du sogar sinnvoll
eingebunden mit der fia
[Musik]
zum 1